c'est l'image de la commission nationale
électorale ce matin sièges vides et
toujours aucun résultat officiel 48
heures après l'élection présidentielle
ivoirienne
vers 13 heures les choses bougent enfin
les journalistes sont brutalement poussé
à l'écart il est commissaire indépendant
molesté à leur tour un groupe de
militaires des commandos veulent
interpeller le président de la
commission au noeud régulier celui là
même chargée de proclamer les résultats
un peu plus tôt les autres membres de la
commission et les observateurs
internationaux de l'union européenne s'y
opposent
il sera finalement conduit de force vers
une destination inconnue
au même moment un communiqué lu au
ministère de l'intérieur
robert guéi wilson 9495 soit 52,72 % en
clair le général gueï le chef de la
junte se proclame vainqueur de
l'élection présidentielle
colère au front populaire ivoirien de
laurent gbagbo qui depuis 48 heures
publie les résultats de procès verbaux
le donnant largement vainqueur laurent
gbagbo réplique je demande que d'un
doute la ville de conway et l'inde ou la
capture les patriotes ivoiriens prennent
la rue jusqu'à ce que le droit soit
reconnu et jusqu'à ce que des études des
besoins c'est moi le seul reliquat des
bulls a aussitôt des masses de
manifestants se déploie dans une ville
déjà quadrillé par les forces de l'ordre
partout dans la ville on érige des
barrages ce soir la situation à abidjan
est insurrectionnel les batailles de
chiffres ont laissé place un face à face
à haut risque entre les civils et
certains militaires